hi there here i am day 22
uh of my 90 day challenge
you know i have to admit it is a bit
hard some days to find the time the
energy to get back at it i haven't done
much today listen to it in the car
you know i play hockey
mondays wednesdays and fridays which i
really really enjoy
uh
and that eats up much of the morning
had some meetings in the office this
afternoon
but what i wanted to talk about today is
language learning is is as i've said
it's like it's like an endurance
uh contest it's it's a marathon it's not
a sprint
and it requires patience and requires
staying with it
and very often we don't realize that
we're making any progress it's it's a
bit like exercising
except when you exercise if you have a
vigorous exercise you actually feel good
like after my hockey i have a i work
very hard in the game i'm really pumping
my legs and skating and win or lose
after the game i have a shower and it
just feels great you walk out of there
hopefully it's a sunny day off and it's
raining here in vancouver but you just
feel good
um unfortunately language learning
doesn't do that for you
there's no noticeable improvement you've
read for an hour you've listened for an
hour you've maybe reviewed your words
for an hour
you don't really notice that you're
getting stronger or fitter or you don't
feel better
so for that reason it's hard to stay
with it
one of the things i try to do is to get
to interesting content as soon as
possible so
at least if i'm reading something and
it's difficult i'm learning so reading
uh the chosen elbow for example it it
gives me some korean perspective on
things and i learned about what's going
on vis-a-vis japan and so forth and so
on uh
i like gekko muskie when i was doing
russian in fact today with the olympics
getting closer and i hope they're a
great success i really do
uh whatever the politics of the
situation
may be
uh it's a tremendous event it's a
tremendous event for russia they've
blown a bunch of money on it but now
it's threatened by these
uh possible you know
terrorist activities and whatnot i hope
it's a great success
uh it would be great to see that part of
the world
uh you know you're getting close to the
middle east the caspian sea iran
for them to have peace and be kind of
brought into
uh the world community with normal
relations and stuff not to a large
extent they are obviously southern
russia is very much part of russia
but it is on the sort of edge of these
areas where there are
some there is some political uncertainty
conflicts
so it'd be great to have a very great
rip-roaring success and i think that's
what the
the president of russia wants to do is
he wants to use this as a as a means of
uh opening that part of russia up and so
forth i wish them all kinds of success
um
now uh but so with the olympics coming
on i stole some time away from korea and
went off to echo mustafi to listen to
some interviews and stuff like that and
of course it's interesting you know
politics comes into language to some
extent so i like to listen to ecommerce
because there's a wide variety of
interesting people on there i don't
necessarily believe everything that
people say
i think it's probably over critical of
the russian government which is probably
not a bad thing because the russian
government controls ninety percent of
the media
so uh you know to have a contrary view
there tolerated by the government by the
way it's probably a good thing
but a lot of russians don't like that i
listen to echo muskie you know so this
guy comes at me oh why do you listen to
how much we and i said well you know
it's interesting and they've got audio
and text and it's interesting that's all
i want
well
you must know that uh no patriotic
russian would listen listen to economist
i mean i'm not a russian and i'm
certainly not a patriotic russian do i
care whether patriotic russians listen
to economic speed
uh i can like the country i don't have
to be sympathetic with all of the
policies of the government it's like
japan i my wife and i love being in
japan we have many good japanese friends
and so forth when the prime minister
goes around saying that
the term invasion has yet to be defined
we don't quite know what that means
as it applies to the japanese invasion
of china and korea and so forth i mean i
don't have to be in sympathy with that
position the term invasion is very well
understood
uh
granted in english it has a little more
neutral meaning whereas the chinese
has more of a sense of an
uh aggressive invasion than the word in
english but it was that too i mean by
the same talking source the uh
you know the in the english or british
presence in india and so forth so
there's a lot of things you can say
about the circumstances that made
japan an imperialist country following
on the footsteps of
european european imperialists but to
deny that in fact they did invade
uh china korea is just charged i can't
imagine why the japanese prime minister
is going around saying these things
anyway
but reading chosen elbow i get into all
these things which i find interesting a
lot of people don't like to talk about
politics i do in fact i would much
rather ramble here on politics than on
language learning but i'm gonna bring it
back to language learning so as i
started to say
language learning
is an endurance contest you have to stay
with it
it's it's like erosion gradually drop
drop drop of water is slowly
making your brain a little more amenable
to the new language you're acquiring new
words you're becoming a little bit more
familiar with the language and so here i
am yesterday i put up 15 minutes of my
discussion with my korean tutor
now in the last 21 days i've been
averaging at least three hours a day of
korea listening reading and vocabulary
review and the occasional review of
grammar rules essentially reading and
listening
i've spoken for maybe a total of two two
and a half hours however there is no
doubt in my mind and judy huns said the
same
my ability to speak to express myself in
korean has improved noticeably just
after three weeks
has improved noticeably compared to when
we last spoke and that basically all
comes from those three weeks of
intensive input
based learning so i've said this before
you can't speak your way to fluency you
eventually have to speak a lot but you
have to listen and read your way
to familiarity with the language to
vocabulary so that you can then when you
start to speak you have something to say
you understand what people are saying my
comprehension is so much better than it
was the last time i spoke to jooheon i
understood most of what she was saying
wonderful i struggled to say what i
wanted to say i was looking for words
occasionally a japanese a japanese word
popped in there what i find is when i'm
trying to speak korean i either go to
japanese in my head
because the word order is the same
and it's a language that i speak much
much better so
were you know languages with that word
order my brain says it's got to be
japanese and of course the last language
that i studied was czech so the other
thing my brain tends to do is oh you're
struggling with the language it'll go to
check so i have to fight that and try
and stay on korean
and so i will simply continue what i'm
doing uh massive listing and reading
which i can fit in like even today i'll
end up with three hours because i had
probably over an hour in the car and i
did a bit of reading this morning i did
a bit of reading this afternoon i'm
gonna do a bit more reading tonight so
it'll end up being three hours so you
can always find the time during the day
but you gotta stay with it even if you
don't have a lot of time you got to
continue doing it and sometimes it's
tough you're tired you'd like to do
other things
and normally i would do other things i
would limit myself probably to an hour
but i'm committed to this 90-day
challenge so i'm trying to push it up to
three hours a day
grinding away
and i'm hoping
that in a week two three weeks from now
or even
at the end of it i will be speaking even
better but most of my activity will be
listening and reading although i may
step up my speaking in another couple of
weeks
anyway that's my comment for